[Music]
Khloe Kardashian became a mom to her
baby girl true on April 12th a month in
a day later shall celebrate her first
Mother's Day it's excited a source tells
ET that the 33 year old mama is planning
to fly from Cleveland to LA with true to
enjoy the festivities with her family
the source tells us quote this is a very
special Mother's Day in the
kardashian-jenner family for Khloe and
Kylie it's their first one and it's
Kim's first Mother's Day with Chicago as
for trues dad tristan thompson the
source says he could be playing
basketball on Mother's Day so it's
unknown if he'll be there Tristan was
accused of cheating on Khloe just days
before true was born our source says the
pair hasn't spent a lot of time together
because of his basketball schedule but
added they are in contact woat the time
alone is good for her she's very
independent and having this space is
essential for her to work through
everything still the source maintains
quote if they work through all this they
still have a long way to go to get back
a solid foundation
you